i will roundhouse kick zach in his face
unless you become a member right now
there are no ads early access
and exclusive discord excess zack's life
is in danger and only you can help him
by becoming a member stay safe
and all the best your friend
chuck norris welcome everybody to the h3
podcast
home of ethan klein your host 5.5 stars
on wikifeet
with my beautiful co-host eli klein i
think you have a 4.97 on wikifee which
is can't compete
which is frankly a really good score but
not a 5.5
no you should i just would like you to
be appreciate more appreciation
yeah yeah that's all i'm saying i want
to talk about feet
okay well this is your episode dan thank
you to
expressvpn for sponsoring us today and
to our wonderful members who help us
immensely thank you guys so very much
um there's also one other thing i
briefly want to point out to you guys
dude we threw up in secret on
h3h3shop.com
literally the ben affleck worst tattoo
of all time shirt
so on the back is the ben affleck tattoo
on the front you get to rep your nace h3
podcast
this is basically the i dare you to wear
this shirt
we should have called it the worst shirt
ever made yeah
we can change the name still so there it
is
i'm not sure who would want to wear it
or why but there it is
i think it's a cool shirt and again like
we're going to get into this but i think
it's a really cool shirt
i love it okay so before we get into
the headline today obviously there's a
lot of juice to nibble on
we've got leafy was banned permanently
from youtube
which tragic news
heartbreaking it is big sad big sad news
i'll get into the nuances of that
obviously and then of course keemstar
is having a full um
i think keemstar is milking i i my
thesis is that keemstar really
is the reason why leafy's banned and now
he's capitalizing on it acting like he's
his friend
we're going to get into that as well and
finally
we have what can only be described as
one of the greatest
segments we've ever done the karen tier
list
we've put together a tier list of all
the cairns all the famous karen's we
have 22 cairns
18 cairns actually we we cut a little
and we're going to put them on a tier
list
to describe to you guys uh
which is the most karen karen and which
is the least karen karen
amazing yeah we got a full show here a
great show
so with that being said let's get right
into it
and uh i want to start it off with a
goof last time we did
you guys may recall this clip
which i had a lot of pleasure to share
with you guys
and so i found one that was somewhat um
similar
that i thought we could all enjoy as
well man trips with mcdonald's
food and rages so let's have a look here
and
kind of you tell me what you think about
this elo
[Music]
what
[Music]
you know he probably wait is that his
house yeah it's just okay
because i thought he was delivering it
at first i think it's his house
i think he probably went on a mcdonald's
run he was starving
he was so excited to eat you know he's
running with with excitement
[Music]
but here here's where i'm like dude you
it didn't have to be
like that if the tops on the sodies
didn't even pop yeah it did not have to
be like that
he could have salvaged this situation
totally just scoop the fries back in
there
or just give up on the fries no scoop
them back in and they're still good
blow on them whatever you got to do dust
them off
i'm not going to let that ruin my
morning dude theodore puts dirt on his
mouth and he's fine
true i can't eat a couple french fries
off the ground
um i think this guy was having a bad day
already
i have to assume
[Applause]
unfortunately
yeah he was over
i feel bad for him i just want to go get
him another
another order fix it for him
but this i think in terms of just
dropping food fails
nothing
but we'll keep looking certainly we'll
keep our the phoenix of uh
the april food oh the the back tack too
yeah yeah i see what you mean
yeah one more time all righty so
um oh there's one other epic freaking
excitement i have to
announce h3 podcast
edison research announces the top 30
podcasts in the united states
the ranker lists the top 30 podcasts in
america by reach not downloads among
weekly podcast consumers
covering the full survey period
this was between july 7th and june
24th of this year i'm assuming july of
last year yeah july of last year to june
this year
wow um they said it's a
it's the first ever all-inclusive study
of the reach of podcast networks
and shows in america and so here
it is and we are on the frickin list at
27.
wow i have to say i was i was pretty
excited and encouraged by that
totally did not expect that yeah i
thought our show was dead
but here it is on the list but joe
rogan's number one obviously
but what really surprised me is there's
no other youtubers on the list
and there's really no other comedies on
the list
a lot of it oh ben shapiro or youtuber
conan o'brien's
yeah conan is conan is mega famous dude
we're definitely in good company i gotta
say it's pretty pretty cool
is ben shapiro a youtuber uh
not i yeah i don't know i don't know
that's a good question
one the only thing i know about bench
bro is that he lets you dry [ __ ]
[Laughter]
the dry [ __ ] experience
but anyway it's a lot of like politics
and stuff and but hey here we are number
27
god bless let's go pretty amazing
next year higher that's right next year
we're taking out call her daddy
by bar barstool sports number 26.
yeah dak shepard more like dax i'm going
to shepherd you into the grave
like just your career not because i'm
going to pass you on to the charts
too much yeah no i have i love that
you want to make it on the list you
probably shouldn't stop by making more
enemies
don't make enemies on the list so i
actually take back
everything i said about mark and dax i
think they're great hosts i think
they're funny guys if they ever want to
help me on their podcast i am 27 in the
world
and uh i think i'd be a great asset to
their show
and i'd love to be on the show so thank
you and i i
am fans and i don't mean any uh ill will
thank you
today we bow our heads for the loss of a
great one
leafy is here was permanently banned
from youtube and i have to say
i almost am impressed i have to admit
the only other person i can remember
being outright banned from youtube is
alex jones and that was a long time ago
and before alex i can't recall really
anyone anybody so
it's almost a compliment to leafy that
that
he provoked that strong of a response
from youtube so in a way i tip my beanie
to him for
for being uh that edgy
he was so edgy he he i feel like he
achieved what he wanted he's just
so edgy that youtube said no more leafy
you're banned right so you know first of
all
i'm impressed i mean you did it dude you
did it so congratulations
and what we've done here before we kind
of get into the details of all this
is we've prepared a little bit of a film
if you would
the life and times of leafy was here
semicolon leafy is no longer here i
believe is the name of the short film
and i'd like to play it for you now and
after that we'll get into all the
details but i i hope you guys enjoy this
you know i would love people saying oh
leafy come back i would love to see
leafy come back and try to exist in the
landscape today
like the content that he was making
would
never fly on youtube today and you have
to adapt and overcome the fact that like
[Music]
you can't even curse bro like like i
don't know
i'd like to see him try to make a
comeback come back come back come back
come back come back dude i survived
i like did the math earlier i survived
143 days
i take that as a dub i tried everything
else bro i tried emailing i tried going
to the normal system
crying on twitter the second it goes on
trending
age restricted crying on twitter bro
it's like they're [ __ ] with me like
i'm convinced
that they get some sort of sick
satisfaction from this or something
crying on twitter instantly age
restricted which i know already said
this in another video but when your
video gets age restricted it gets
removed off trending
crying on twitter i think they get some
sick satisfaction out of this
i'm not gonna [ __ ] about this for eight
hours but just know i could i don't
think my videos are as harsh as they
used to be not even close
but i don't think the videos themselves
were that toxic
we saw this tweet of someone actually
saying that they were going to kill
pokemane
here's leafy suggesting to use an hdr
recon scope what caused this what do you
think happened like if you had to guess
because you don't know anything
uh i have no idea pokeman isn't even
attractive
there's really no other way of saying it
she's just not hot dude
she's just really not hot the average
person on twitch is more attractive than
pokeman
at least with the titty streamers a lot
of them are hot pokeman really doesn't
have that going for
so much i'm thinking three out of ten uh
if not you know actually keemstar
probably had it right yeah it was super
random dude
to wrap up this video i think this guy
definitely took the dub
i i don't think anyone's gonna be able
to beat him i mean
i think there should be another award
for the most creative ones and the most
creative ways of
pissing off the tier three subs anyways
whoever wins gets 500 bucks
no i had i had one i think warning when
i have an idea or when i have a cow that
just keeps producing milk
i'm just gonna keep milking it until the
milk dries up and the cow has been
milked to this point of complete utter
exhaustion
and at the same time complete utter
efficiency until that point
until the cow is it's not even dead
until the cow is non-existent
i'm assuming at this point some people
are wondering when am i going to stop
and the answer is never i'm never going
to stop or if i had to be honest most
likely when i get banned
she has a boyfriend let me say that one
more time dude she has a boyfriend and
you're [ __ ] pathetic after you guys
get done donating to her
she goes and [ __ ] someone else and i
get a dm from one of his very close
friends
and this is what they said to me
honestly
leafy liked you too but he said he can't
date anyone
because it will make his female fans and
something else
you guys hear that do you guys [ __ ]
hear that
what the [ __ ] is that did you guys hear
that what the [ __ ]
oh god i i don't understand how are we
winning right now
tell the people mad dude it's just luck
i think god just loves me that's
something
i don't know got this is like actual
plot armor irl
and this is like the simulation year for
me this is just it's like going too well
like actually too whoa wow
whoa am i already banned
bro i'm already banned
well there you have it a little bit
up to speed here i'm gonna get into all
the details of that but i hope you guys
enjoyed that
you know the first thing i had to tweet
when i
learned about this was that i had to
tweet this
um i would love to see leafy try and
exist
in today's current landscape when
slasher this is when i first learned
about when slasher tweeted out leafy's
youtube account has been terminated
due to multiple or severe violations of
youtube's policy prohibiting
content designed to harass bully or
threaten
and you know leafy literally
that clip the in the beginning of that
edit leafy put at the end of all of his
videos
of me saying i'd love to see leafy tran
exist in today's current
landscape it didn't bother me actually i
thought it was funny and fair
you know to try but the problem is that
when you invest so heavily
and that and then when you do get banned
you look like a [ __ ] idiot i'm sorry
dude i was right
i mean it's just i feel like i'm not
getting enough credit for that i was
right
and like the dude he invested so much
in this meme every video
i was writing the whole [ __ ] time
dude
so i mean i feel like i get a little bit
of a right to tweet this because a lot
of people were
angry somehow that i tweeted this
i would love to see leafy try and exist
in today's current climate
and then some people were saying that
you're celebrating is ben
how am i celebrating i'm
literally am i not entitled after this
guy put this in
every single one of his videos for 140
days or whatever he said
that i don't even get to it i i have a
moral obligation
to tweet this do you understand i have a
professional
personal obligation to tweet this
it's been not celebrating dude it's like
ordained by god
you know as the listen as the host of
the number 27 podcast of the united
states i am
obligated to tweet this out
because it's written like poetry i mean
come on so people are angry
that i i just can't win you know what i
mean it's like in some people's minds
there's literally no way for me to win
the dude the dude is trying to clown on
me for like three or four months and
then
i'm proven right tweet it out and
somehow i'm still the bad [ __ ] guy
but okay i can handle that you know
so here's a timeline because he went on
dramaalert
and i've seen a lot of people saying and
defensively feed that a
he should have got a warning first
there's one thing i keep hearing
b uh it's somehow like some kind of free
speech
thing and we should all be worried
because all of us can be
in next all of us could be next now that
youtube's been to sleep for you
my personal opinion on this which i'll
try to prove to you guys
is that the only thing that surprised me
is that
that youtube didn't ban him sooner and
i'm not saying that i
that because i'm saying i'm agreeing
with their decision i'm just saying
he was invite he clearly violated all of
their rules
and uh he and he he even went as far as
to taunt them he literally says at one
point
i will never stop making pokey videos
until they banned me
literally he literally said that yeah so
i don't understand why everybody's so
shocked and surprised by the fact that
he got banned and how they're trying to
make it into this whole big
uh social issue it's just it's just not
let me show you guys what i'm talking
about and you can make up your own
decision
so first of all one of the things that i
constantly hear is that he was banned
without any warning
did you have any strikes prior to your
channel being terminated because i know
you got some in the past but
like you complained to youtube and they
reversed them so that they made a
mistake
no i had i had one i think warning but i
had no strikes besides that
so yeah it was super random dude what do
you think a warning mean
that doesn't sound like it was random at
all a warning sounds like a warning
a warning literally means that you're on
thin
ice it was super random bro they told me
not to do that and they gave me an
official warning
i was so shocked i totally didn't see
this coming
i was blocked i had a bunch of videos
removed i
had a warning i totally didn't see this
gummy
do you think it's ironic that leafy was
using are
like the content nuke template that we
used on keemstar
and it's ironic and not cool to steal
our original idea
right well what i was thinking was that
it was ironic that he nuked himself
because you've got to understand the
power of nuclear energy you can't just
you can't just have your a manhattan
project and not
know what how to handle the material
safely because he tried to destroy pokey
but in the end
leafy's channel's banned yeah just an
iron just something that's kind of funny
to point out
anyway let's continue forth
here we go well you were uploading
videos with a pokemon
uh pokeman thumbnail right but then the
content was you
teaching your uh you know your viewers
about
investments in the stock market so yeah
like the whole joke of those videos is
just that you know it looks that toxic
but i don't think the videos themselves
were that toxic uh this is another
argument i hear is that
yes i made 15 videos about pokemane and
the thumbnail and title
but if you actually watch the videos i
was talking about investing or
whatever he was talking about but again
that is a violation of the community
guidelines you can't have misleading
thumbnails and titles where you say um
you know
you can't say pokemon see your pokemane
see your sponsors later lol
and then not even talk about it so that
that in itself is a violation
i was try i'm trying to dig into how he
actually did get banned
because like i said in the beginning
like youtube is super
conservative with this stuff like i know
that they
like they tend to not really do these
kinds of things
so i'm trying to see all the things so
here's here's one
bye bye pokeman haha someone says
someone needs to kill pokeman
and it has 1400 likes that doesn't seem
very funny that that to me
seems like extraordinarily [ __ ] up and
leafy responded hdr recon
scope um
i don't know when i saw this i was does
anyone really think this is funny or
cool
i mean it's kind of horrifically uh
irresponsible and disgusting it seems to
me like he does
but you have to acknowledge that this is
so irresponsible of you to
to even engage in a comment like that
even if his response is not
technically serious because he's
mentioning whatever it is
just the fact that he's even engaging in
a comment like that you
you can't you have a responsibility you
can't do that
because you're you're promoting it i
mean i would block this person
right if i saw that if on a video i was
making fun of someone
but the thing is a comment like this
probably had like maybe a few likes and
then he responded to it and that's
exactly why i'm saying it you can't even
engage in something like this because
then
you're validating it and you're bringing
more attention to it
if i'm youtube and i see this i'm like
this guy this kid
it's dangerous this is horri this is
horrific i mean this is just
crazy i'm sorry this is crazy i mean
this alone is like
horrific i don't know that's a strike
for sure
immediately i know it's on twitter but i
don't know dude you can't do that
that's [ __ ] up like just just from a
human
humanistic perspective from pokeman if i
was her
i would just be like dude what i would
be very disturbed
and actually scared yeah myself like
dude you can make fun of me but like now
you're
people are saying i'm gonna kill her and
you think that's some kind of funny joke
you don't know who that person is or the
1400 people who like that tweet
and that's also part of the thing about
when you make 15 videos about someone
even if you're not talking about them in
the video you're just riling people up
and getting them all crazy and it's like
pokeman is turned into this inhuman
monster that people just can just say i
want to kill her
and that's somehow funny joke okay so
that that to me is horrific
so it looks like we're already up to uh
two strikes with misleading thumbnails
we've got death threats on twitter
we've got harassment 15 videos about
someone
uh and then i mean again once again if
i'm youtube and i see something like
this clip here
making a few videos on pokemon um
i'm assuming at this point some people
are wondering when am i going to stop
and the answer is never i'm never going
to stop or if i had to be honest
most likely when i get banned or just
complete utter burnout i mean that's
usually been my style
i hope this isn't shocking to anyone but
moderation has never been my style
when i have an idea or when i have a cow
that just keeps producing milk
i'm just gonna keep milking it until the
milk dries up and the cow has been melt
to this point of complete utter
exhaustion
and at the same time complete utter
efficiency until that
point until the cow is it's not even
dead
until the cow is non-existent until i've
grinded up the bones of the cow and used
the hoofs
into a big stew anyway he says he's
never going to stop until he's banned
right he said that right sounds pretty
self-aware sounds like someone who
shouldn't be surprised
that's exactly that's my point now all
of a sudden when he got banned he's
acting like he
there he doesn't understand why it
happened he literally
said i will never stop until i get
banned
oh and then so i i have a feeling that
this next one had a big reason why
why he was back i just spent two so uh
in one of his videos about pokey
he made up a game for his audience
to go raid her discord and see how
quickly
they could get banned and he even went
as far to
link the url in the video of the discord
and offered a cash prize to whoever
could get banned the fastest
i mean this is a direct call to action
in a video
to his audience to go harass somebody i
mean guys this is
this is not
this is not a mystery no i mean this is
this is really cool
power's doing that i hope you guys
enjoyed that segment or something like
that to wrap up this video i think this
guy definitely took the dub
i i don't think anyone's gonna be able
to beat him i mean
[Music]
so here he puts the discord link
uh he says to everybody go join her
discord
and at one point he did offer a cash
prize didn't he
or was that before i think it's coming
up right after that
okay this is him trying to do a speed
run
i think he might have mathematically
solved the pokemon discord band speed
run
but hey maybe someone else would beat
him i don't know i don't think someone
will to be honest
even though this guy definitely gets the
win for the speed running award
i think there should be another award
for the most creative ones and the most
creative ways of
pissing off the tier three subs i mean
i'm not gonna lie i tried to win that
award myself today i tried doing the
reptile and the kim jong-un [ __ ] but it
just didn't work
i mean i guess this is kind of like a
game of seeing who can like
piss the closest to the electric fence
and dude i didn't even get two messages
out
like i thought reptile would work same
with kim jong-un i guess not
but whatever man anyways whoever wins
gets 500 bucks
and also in fact
yeah that's pretty wild i've never seen
anyone engage in
something like that and just not even
try to hide
it uh zach do you have a sound bite of
him saying uh i don't know why or
anything like that
that would be a great time
literally literally okay take that
take what i can get in this case so is
it a mystery
is it a mystery that leafy was banned no
so with this that's like five strikes i
can count on my hand
and like really flagrant [ __ ] too
so you know i've got this is this is
really horrific
behavior i mean i don't i don't i don't
want this [ __ ] on youtube i just feel
like
if any one of us would do this stuff we
would get banned and it's pretty clear
to us yeah because i see people like um
scarce or other youtubers expressing
concern that they feel like this is a
red flag
because they could be next i haven't
seen any of you guys do this stuff
you know i haven't seen anyone else do
this kind of stuff so
it's the 15 videos it's the misleading
thumbnails
it's the joking about killing her it's
encouraging the audience to go rate her
discord and try to get banned and giving
a cash prize
i mean dude there's this whole thing of
like they came for leafy and
you laughed and next they came for you
and nobody was there it's like dude
no the guys the guy definitely had it
coming
and pretty much his whole channel seems
like an experiment
like he was checking how far he can push
it before he gets yeah
i think he should just own it yeah why
he has to act like a little [ __ ] now
and act like he's all surprised
and act like he's the martyr of youtube
i thought you were some edgy
[ __ ] kid that didn't give a [ __ ]
about anything and all of a sudden you
care
where's the apathy now dude just don't
be a little [ __ ]
and own the fact that you got a speed
run ban and that you've got the world
record and
and i'll give you props for that i mean
i'll give you props for that
but the fact is that you you're trying
to have it both way you're trying to
have your cake and eat it too where
you're like
i'm gonna keep doing this until i get
banned and on the other hand you go on
twitter and cry and [ __ ] on
drum alert about how you're a [ __ ]
martyr and what i'm surprised is that so
many people
fall for it when you are clearly just
trying to get banned
you just gotta own that stop being a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he's such a baby ass [ __ ] crying
i can't believe so many people bought it
i mean dude
you really you guys really want kind the
kind of content where creators
go put your discord and give a cash
prize for whoever can find the most
creative way to harass you
really scarce did i mean i maybe they
don't know about all this stuff
i'm assuming i don't think they do yeah
but like again so why are they giving
him so much benefit of the doubt i just
don't get it
it's [ __ ] leafy dude i would like to
congratulate him on the speed
run youtube band that i'll definitely
give him props for
but the fact that he's out here crying
like a little [ __ ]
[ __ ] that i mean dude what happened to
the edgy cool kid apathy dude
you know what the [ __ ] dude anyway he
goes on
i wish keemstar would have told him
because i remember when keemstar got his
uh
uh he blocked the podcast i love that he
preemptively blocked the podcast uh
twitter keemstar because when keemstar
got his two-week suspension he
cried and apologized and he's like
youtube i'm so sorry i now understand
there are rules that we need to follow
but at the same time he's interviewing
leafy being like this is outrageous
he's a martyr like dude here
let's watch keemstar cry about the rules
here to also
spread the message out to the community
of what the rules are
because you shouldn't reported that
video i didn't think i was breaking the
rules but
um that that is how strict youtube uh
is on the bullying and harassment uh
guidelines and i understand where
they're coming from they're trying to
make the platform better
right for creators right and um based on
talking to them i understand that i
broke the rules
and that i am sorry oh he's so sorry he
broke the rules
fast forward to him talking to leafy
this is outrageous
dude what did you do i don't understand
i mean dude
your buddy leafy could have used your
insight man
you had an awakening why didn't you tell
leafy about it wasn't it interesting
that the [ __ ] bad guy
keem is the one that kind of like
instigated this whole thing so he kind
of baited leafy into getting
into kamikaze in his channel in a way
dan
one billion percent who benefits from
this
keemstar who who started
the pokeman rumor that she has a
boyfriend
keemstar keemstar basically got
leafy banned or put him up to it i feel
like keemstar
totally uh puppet puppet master leafy
he's using leafy to
to to every end he wants let's see he
went on dramaalert
he gave him an exclusive interview now
he's on story fire which i'm pretty sure
keemstar is a
or dumpster fire i don't know is it
dumpster fire or story fire
anyway he uh i genuinely couldn't
remember the name
and so now keemstar who owns dumpster
fire
leafy is on that platform huge
w for for keemstar right he's going on
his podcast your mom's
uh basement yeah your mom's basement
and uh and so i feel like keemstar is
benefiting
greatly from all of this and he's and he
got leafy to go out there and stir up
all this drama
for him to report on dramaalert and now
his channel is banned
and kimser's like i had no idea that
that youtube
could could do this and meanwhile he
literally posted a video on twitter
saying i am so sorry that i did this and
now i understand the rules
dude keemstar [ __ ] you leafy
like he used you abused you and spit you
out
and [ __ ] and wiped his ass with you
and milked you for every dime and dollar
it's crazy how how you don't see that
it's crazy how you don't see that to me
but enjoy your mom's
your mom's basement or whatever and i'm
sure that uh
keemstar will will benefit greatly from
you being on dumpster fire
i'm the [ __ ] bad guy right that's
what i that's what i think too
totally yeah it's nice to hear him say
that for once
uh i think we're at break time okay um
when we come back keemstar threatened to
sue us so
i know i don't want to i don't want to
linger too long on this but i had to
address this because it's just so good
so we'll throw it to a quick break
when we come back keemstar is suing us
thank you very much to expressvpn for
sponsoring us
expressvpn lets you access the internet
as if you're using it in
any country you choose that means that
if you want to watch something on
netflix
or any of these other platforms you know
they have different
libraries for the different uh country
you're connecting from for example
japan netflix has got all kinds of crap
you can't even watch here in the usa for
example all of miyazaki's films are on
there
and so there's just a ridiculous amount
of content there's going to be
unlocked to you when you access
expressvpn
not only that but their uh
their vpn is ridiculously fast you can
stream everything in hd quality
with zero buffering and you can use it
on every device
phones laptops tablets and even your tv
i'm talking netflix
amazon prime bbc iplayer youtube and
many many more
you can choose from almost 100 different
countries and each country's got their
own content to unlock
it's so simple to use all you got to do
is fire up the expressvpn app
change your location hit connect and
then refresh the page and the show
remover you want to watch will
magically appear i
i use expressvpn when i want to watch
anime and miyazaki stuff
netflix japan freaking rules
and uh i mean that alone makes it worth
it i'm a weeaboo like that
here's the extra little bonus if you use
our link right now
not only will you be supporting our show
which thank you for doing that
uh you'll also be getting
three an extra three months
for free expressvpn.com
h3 three extra months for free at
expressvpn that's
expressvpn.com
h3
so i actually do want to make a quick
correction i said that kim starr
owns some of storyfire uh
i don't know if that's true i do know
he's an advisor
on he took an advisory role and he says
that he
works with them recruiting creators
so i definitely so i don't know if he
owns some of dumpster fire necessarily
but what i do know is that he's
definitely benefiting from leafy and
other people
signing up for to join the dumpster fire
um okay moving on so keepstar is
threatening to sue us okay
now this is something that i just had
had to acknowledge coming of course from
comment cop who i have one of these
twitter accounts you really should
follow
this guy's on another level of just
collecting wild [ __ ] here's here here's
keemstar acting tough
i ignore everything to do with the man
right like i have like a bunch of people
were building a case he's cost me about
close to half a million dollars in
damages
uh i'm gonna wait until the last day and
then i'm literally gonna take the teddy
fresh away
i'm not even exaggerating i have like
literally a three-man
crew on this stuff and like i don't know
anything that's going on with him like i
purposely ignore it
and i'll probably get in trouble for
what i just said by my legal team but
like at the end of the day at the end of
the day
like i mean when it's all said and done
it could be millions and millions of
dollars that he's actually
costing me um so i mean i'm not
i'm not allowed to say like how much i
understand that yeah
one year's salary is astronomical
like i can't say what that is but from
what i assume i think it makes sense i
think you i don't know i'll tell you
offline about it
by the way these are all the same guys
who were like
so up in arms about the fact that i
mentioned g fuel
oh wait here there's there's actually
one more part he also
he also put a bunch of information out
there that is like
it's false right like it's it's not
reality
um and you know he he did it in a way
to hurt me like so when you go to court
you have to prove that this
person had malicious intent i can prove
that he had malicious intent
i can prove that he did this so my
sponsors would drop me
right like i can prove that in a court
of law without a shadow of a doubt
and i'm gonna take your kids college
fund and it's
making me happy ah we love keemstar
he's taking the teddy fresh and he's
taking uh theodore's college fund away
which is making him happy
now these are the same guys they thought
the fact that i mentioned g-field was
was uh basically uh uh
i i crucified jesus christ i killed the
i kill
i i opened pandora's box right committed
the greatest crime but here's keemstar
saying
he's gonna sue me
and take my college kids fund away and
somehow they don't have any problem with
that
right that that's fine now here's the
thing keemstar has such a hilarious
misunderstanding of how the law works
that i almost i just want to look in
this camera and say keemstar
you are so and that's not defamation
that's true
that's provably true i could prove that
beyond a shadow of a doubt
you are the most
alive and let me tell you i know exactly
what you do bro it's so
it's so this is what keemstar does he
misrepresents people what people say
to the point of lying about them to
provoke a response and create drama
but i just have to literally first of
all keemstar
tell me one thing how is it that you're
gonna
prove damages when you
[ __ ] said this and because of all the
hate that g gfuel recently got from your
stupid [ __ ] video
i i i got in contact with them i'm i'm
no longer with g
fuel anymore i walked away you what
you walked away and somehow you want to
blame me for damages
see this is why you're so it's because
you want to act like a tough guy
you want to act like you're in control
and that that
that you're some great mastermind when g
fuel dropped you like a
paint that you are and so you had to go
on and be like
i dropped you but but see
now good luck suing me when you're on
record saying i walked away
but not that it even matters because you
don't even understand what defamation is
you see
when you go to court defamation is not
proven by trying to cause damages you
what did shoes and i say
i can't remember let me explain sit down
keep star let me give you a little
education see i've been through this i
know a little bit something about it
lots of people always try to cause
damage you could make that argument
about almost anybody that says anything
negative about anybody
i mean keemstar go look at your channel
90
100 of your videos is saying horrible
things about people
that is probably going to prevent them
from getting sponsors
defamation is proven when somebody
knowingly
lies about you that's what you have to
prove
not that i was trying to get your
sponsors dropped you
like literally just read online i know
you sound tough when you're trying to
impress all these [ __ ] 12 year olds
around you about that you know what
about how legal [ __ ] works but but here
now let me give you an example of what
the
actual defamation is imagine you go on
your
your drama alert and you say ethan
steals money
and then then i go and i correct the
record
and the owner of the game says no ethan
didn't steal the money
that was meant for him and then that
video stays up see that
is actionable defamation because
you know that it's wrong and you keep it
up and
therefore the damn therefore i can
charge you for the damages it causes
did that make sense hila see that's
defamation you have no understanding
no concept of what that means i welcome
you to sue me dude
i will get that thrown out so [ __ ]
fast and easy on a summary i wouldn't
have to go to summary judgment keemstar
i could get that
i could get that gone on motion to
dismiss on the pleadings
and i could probably counter sue for
charges too because it's just such a
[ __ ]
like uh it's like a malicious
meritless lawsuit and the good thing is
i actually have talked to an attorney
and he says that what keemstar did do
about me
is actionable but i've been through it
and i and i it's just not worth it you
know what i mean
it's not worth it but i i but if he
wanted to go as far as to sue
us then i would definitely once we're
there i would of course
sue him for defamation which actually is
it actually is defamation
ah just this is keemstar trying to sue
me for defamation
you know what i mean i mean i just get
so fired up by what a [ __ ] idiot he
is
and he's just so eager to try to prove
how in control and everything and i mean
he really this is keemstar really at the
end of the day
i mean dude the guy is such a [ __ ]
loser it's it's hard to even fathom
and how he surrounds himself with all
these kids that just like
not i mean dude dude did a podcast from
inside someone's closet
talking about how he's gonna sue me i
mean jesus man
but anyway the number one supporter of
cancel culture
say that again is you're coming to quiet
but i'm the number one supporter of
cancel culture
oh wow that's what i'm saying i mean
dude that's literally all you do
if you could just sue someone based on
damages you would be you would be
oblivious
obliterated what are you saying
what i'm saying is that is that i
welcome you to try to sue me
keemstar i mean
by the way i love how he goes i've got
three lawyers i've got a whole legal
team working around the clock
maybe you should look into what i'm
saying because you might be getting
ripped off dude yeah exactly
they're like yeah we'll need a retainer
of 20 000 a month
i'm gonna take your kids college fund
and it's making me happy
okay cool well i welcome you to try
to to that yes go [ __ ] yourself you
little hustling little
[ __ ] okay calm down keemstar we're just
trying to have a civil debate
you know i love how he goes i'm taking
the teddy fresh it reminds me of matt
haas he said the same thing
he literally said the same thing
matt haas goes i'm taking your youtube
channel that's what he said to us
i'm taking your youtube channel it's
going to be called i'm going to own h3h3
productions now
[Music]
um yeah you might want to hook up with
him keem he has good experience trying
to sue us
i'm literally gonna take the teddy fresh
away
i think he would be i think he would be
in good hands i think he'd be a really
good designer
based on the evil acid i'm the [ __ ]
bad guy
yes keemstar that's what i'm trying to
say he's finally talking sense
anyway and and i do want to make one
final point on keemstar since i'm here i
haven't talked about them in so long so
indulge me if you would please
i know you're this isn't your cup of tea
but because keemstar is so
anti-platforming deep sorry keemstar is
so
anti-d platforming he's such a free
speech warrior
and everyone should be able to do and
say whatever they want even if that
includes uh making death threats against
somebody
i would like to draw your attention to
one video
of keemstar talking to them i used to go
to a man
in fact i'll let this video speak for
itself and just remember if keemstar's
channel ever does get banned
just play him this video
well this is a great one i i think you
guys will enjoy this i used to go by the
name
brookbong returns but at the moment i go
by mr btfo
made me had to change my name because
people were literally non-stop
trying to flag me down i've had people
targeting me impersonating me trying to
get into my accounts and go after me and
my family
and partially some of this is due to
keemstar because i
made a video on one of his friends he
went after me big time i have been
like [ __ ] with you non-stop taking
down your twitches
taking down your twitters taking down
every social media platform you have
mr bond and uh i've been
owning you he went after everything he
went after
anything that i could make money online
to get me taken off stream me
when he owned a percentage he went after
my twitter
my youtube my twitch and i was doing
really well on all these by the way
he is just non-stop had people going
after me
i mean keemstar himself in this video
admits to going after my finances
anywhere i could make money he's taking
down my twitter
my twitch my youtube multiple times and
i am your god
and i mean that you're healthy
i'm your god [ __ ] god because
anything you create i [ __ ] destroy
like that and i've been doing it
over and over and over and over
again but he was going after my family
as well all because
i exposed people that he didn't want
exposed angry grandpa's son
who kept monetizing his dad's death
consistently and people wanted to make
videos on the guy
but they have been too scared to i've
tried to tell multiple youtubers about
this i've tried to send them the clip
they don't give a [ __ ] because i'm not
relevant anymore
all right your twitters gone
your [ __ ] uh twitches gone
your youtube channel gone so hold on let
me let me get something clear
leafy was banned on youtube
but he still has accounts elsewhere so
is that the platforming
tech's not fully platforming no i mean
so what do you call it when you
when you are celebrating the removal of
someone from twitter
twitch youtube and every platform what
do you call that
deep platforming that's what it's called
it's called deep platforming
also i would like to note that he is
celebrating he's gr
groveling and his victory yes keemstar
the champion of free speech i
am untouchable but you are not you've
lost
everything you live with your mom and
dad
all right live with your mom and dad and
make no money
because every little outlet that you had
to make a few bucks is shut down
by me and i'm going to continue doing it
over and over and over again that's
perfect control
fetish for like power and control it's
creepy as [ __ ]
is this video so creepy i feel like this
really gives you a glimpse into the kind
of dude he is i mean
the dude doesn't stand for anything like
he just did a whole
episode with leafy about how
what does it mean deplatforming oh you
didn't deserve it
you don't stand for anything about what
other than what benefits you because how
can that same dude go on and say this to
someone else
it's literally incompatible
have something you don't have i have
friends
that work at twitter friends that's
literally what he accuses me of
that work at twitch friends that work at
youtube that's literally what he accuses
me of that he's openly saying
is it because that's what he does
so he assumes other people are like that
too right
you know but why is it that i am somehow
george source of youtube and and people
just it's crazy the past he gets
by the from the commentary community
who's just super they just
they somehow just don't they're afraid
of him
yeah yeah right but like dude
he literally is always accusing me
i mean his whole conspiracy theory is
that i got leafy's
video shut down because i took a picture
with susan once like
two or three years ago which i'll never
understand all these people that think
that you got leafy's video removed
if you had that power why wouldn't you
do that to keem
you [ __ ] hate keem a few sometimes
more than leafy oh that's for sure and
by the way i don't want to say i do want
to say for the record that i was really
not bothered by leafy's meme it didn't
bother me i swear to god you may not
believe me but
i i i totally just thought
it's fine i mean it's fine he can do
that it's fine the meme
yeah oh and then the meme had
transformed too where people were like
i'd like to see leafy
over at my house for tea like people
just turned it into this whole crazy
meme where it
took all these different turns and stuff
and it took on a life of its own and
that's fine
uh keemstar is is an evil
well you know my thing is i think
keemstar just totally used and abused
and disposed of leafy so
yeah keemstar is a piece of [ __ ] and
he's just a total [ __ ] hypocrite in
the worst way possible
i am [ __ ] untouchable but you are not
and the proof that you're not
untouchable is all your accounts that
have been shut down for the last couple
months
and i'm gonna start [ __ ] with your
boys too
untouchable remember that untouchable
brit bong
untouchable you can't do [ __ ] to me but
i've done a lot to you when i say i'm
going to [ __ ] own you
i need it because i've done it over and
over and over again i've done it all
summer
bro where's your twitter where's your
twitch
where's your youtube they're gone i'm
gonna keep
[ __ ] with you i've been in internet
wars
before you were even on the internet kid
you're a [ __ ] rookie
no one cares i get banned no one tells
people i've been banned no one is that
it i know there was more yeah i guess
that's it so that's
so i mean again the dude doesn't give a
[ __ ] about the platforming he'll do it
to anybody else
you know what i mean same thing with the
whole thing about how i can't believe
you went after my sponsors i mean you
were doing
you've always done that i mean and then
j station it's like okay
everyone says yeah i know nobody likes
leafy but like do we really want to
to get rid here's i mean keemstar
youtube needs to delete this channel
stop j station once again the biggest
[ __ ] hypocrite just
uh i mean it's beyond hypocrisy it's
just
plain sociopathy it's pure
he's he stands for literally nothing and
what was the j station and that was over
him faking his girlfriend's death he he
dude j station was a [ __ ] dumpster
fire dude he did all kinds of crap
he faked his girlfriend's death he did
ouija boards with people who just passed
away i mean he's a shitty dude right
yeah
but again doesn't the same logic apply
to j station as it does to leafy
of course if you're really a free speech
absolute like if that if this is what it
is then this is what it is
but no i'm the [ __ ] bad guy this is
from
six months ago is that right who took
this is this really from six months ago
i think so six months ago this
isn't even that old he was for deep
platforming jstation
six months ago you guys do you see how
substanceless
this man is he stands for nothing
garbage garbage
holy crap i can't believe that was just
six months ago i thought he'd be like
yeah i was old i changed my mind like he
did about the uh
that one clip of him trying to get this
one team's
sponsors cancelled because it was old it
was different back then
february 4th 2020. yeah this just
happened
um oops yeah he is talking about j
station let's see what he says
miller spirit box challenge at 3 a.m
speaks about ariana grande
that's right j station uploaded a fake
video pretending
that he was talking about pretend to
actually be outraged
by anything i have no feelings or
emotions though
literally just trying to pretend so that
i can act
so that you think that i'm a human being
jack miller and mac miller was saying
tell ariana i love her and again why was
he not
canceled because he has children fans
children watching oh my god i'm drowning
in irony dude
he's setting such a bad example to these
children
recently kobe bryant just passed away
and one of jstation's fans
decided to upload his own video of
calling kobe
wait hold on you're holding him
responsible for what his fans do
kobe bryant at 3 a.m oh my god he
actually answered he's alive
and actually a couple months ago
jstation uploaded
another video and you're gonna think
this is fake but this is on youtube this
is real
and there were no consequences to this
jstation uploaded this video
titled i bought a slave off the dark web
and i finally unmasked the slave off the
dark web and to make matters worse
the so-called slave he bought on the
dark web
is a black gentleman oh keemstar
don't get me started about race i'm not
a democrat
well that's for sure oh here's another
one what is this
and i know others trying to cancel shane
dawson
let's see youtube creators are deathly
afraid that this is going to cause
another ad apocalypse so we're just
we're just hoping that youtube can
somehow
do something to like fix this or
have some accountability for some of
this stuff that happened on their
platform
what because quite frankly youtube
taking shane's apology and putting on
number one trending
[Music]
doesn't really look that good for
youtube not gonna lie moving on
moving on this was um this video was
from two months ago
of him begging youtube to hold shane
responsible
i mean dude you are literally
empty inside you are for d platforming
people you don't like you are for
removing sponsors from people you don't
like whenever it benefits you
and then you you'll act like this
perfect [ __ ]
a victim this perfect martyr for all
those things
i mean hypocrisy doesn't even describe
what you are
jesus man how do you even show your face
bro
it's just embarrassing how embarrassing
to be keemstar
it's got to be one of the most
embarrassing things in the world to look
in the mirror and just be like damn i'm
keemstar no wonder he's so angry
every morning can you imagine you wake
up and you're like oh
[ __ ] not that guy again when you look in
the mirror
you're like oh okay i'm feeling pretty
good oh [ __ ] i'm
game star you see this [ __ ] on my face
it's crazy man what a douche
so that's pretty much it eh oh and then
he has the balls
let's see so he has the balls to tweet
out that his
he he's mad because him using leafy
didn't work out as good as he wanted
he goes leafy interviews only 10 out of
10.
no way monetized and that means
he's referring to the performance of it
on youtube
yeah you can see here he shows
everything
i just don't think many people
understand what that means
oh yeah well he tweets it all the time
he has like a leaderboard and so it
tells you
how your video is performing in
comparison to your last 10 videos
and his is his leafy interview was
performing 10
out of 10 the worst performing one and
so keemstar is like
hold on i got my buddy banned for this
interview
and it literally didn't even get me that
many views
it must be that i'm being suppressed
yeah it must be
can you imagine this is keemstar every
morning oh [ __ ] not that [ __ ] again
no good i think it's funny expect more
laughs
laughter so why are you putting out fake
news
for me bro what's g what that what's
that game
so why are you putting out fake news to
try to cancel me bro
i know i think everything i said is true
i mean
i mean go ahead and sue me for
defamation like you want i mean
i don't think not true i don't think you
understand what defamation
is to be perfectly honest because the
way you described it
is not what defamation is prove it
i mean you said you wanted to sue me
what do i have to prove
but i'm the number one supporter of
cancel culture
right we know that now right right i
mean yeah we just showed that
without it beyond the shadow of a doubt
that's true
all right thank you keemstar uh
that felt that was cathartic how do you
think that went
i had to get i haven't talked about this
stuff in a while so
you know he's just they're just both of
them i mean
leafy's a [ __ ] he just doesn't own it
he's gonna cry
and keemstar actually just [ __ ] used
leafy like a
i want to say use tampon
you know what i mean he just took it out
of his badge and
tried to flush it but you're not
supposed to flush tampons
so he clogged the toilet and then he had
to reach in and get the
tampon out and dispose of it properly
[Laughter]
was that vin diesel right or wrong
all right we can't get back into this
let's move on so
we've got now our final segment that i'm
very excited about
the karen tier list
you guys are aware of the phenomenon of
karen i'm sure
how would you describe it it's like
women who
is it white women is it specifically
white women um
i think so yeah i feel like it is it's
like entitled
white women who just we have like 20
videos or something and they're all
white women so yeah
it is a phenomenon i have to say i've
just entitled white women that just
like feel like the rules and ordinary
society doesn't apply to them for some
reason
well before we get started i do want to
say i'm sorry to all the cool karens out
there
because their name is just ruined
forever yeah that sucks i don't know how
do you live as a karen right now
yeah i mean you were living like up
until two years ago you're just living a
normal life as a karen and then all of a
sudden it's like
oh your name's karen i don't even know
how it happened like why
karen yeah i'm hoping for them it will
this meme is kind of dying out
and in a couple of years they'll be able
to go back to normal life yeah
but if all of a sudden ethan was like a
douche like everything was
a douche i'd be like damn yeah
i thought i was the only douche now i
[ __ ] up my whole name
all my name bears is there like a
nickname
that karen's can adopt to to avoid the
karen label
it's not really like a oh you want like
a like a k-dog or some [ __ ]
so what what our objective here is today
is that we've got 18
karen of the most infamous karen videos
a lot of these i haven't seen
and i want to rank them on a tier list
from s to f
now how do we decide on the power scale
of a karen basically just by
how cariny she is right like how bad is
she
as a parent or good depending on how you
define it
but does that make sense to do the
criteria make sense
yeah i suppose i mean uh you know
sometimes the way that the karen
energy expresses itself um can vary
quite a bit you know
there's kind of the the more psychotic
freakouts the racist ones
there's like the anti-mask ones and so
yeah you know there's got to be kind of
like a through line there somehow
i agree i think it's just the general
insanity of the karen
but let's let's let's watch our first
one
uh if this winds up on youtube i'm suing
you
that sounds pretty good oh here we are
sounds like keemstar
taking my money so you need to give me
my cash and if i end up on youtube
i will personally sue your ass i'm just
talking about
this oh it's a group of characters
i'm not laughing now you want me to show
you on my phone that you are
please that you are what laughing
if we end up on youtube i will see you
i'm not putting it on youtube
dude that baby is so unfazed i feel like
they must be like this all the time
all right that is gonna say ready yeah
because you can't record anything
right let me tell you my attorney i love
you
okay
did you get your money
i don't know what they're fighting about
let's see maybe it's in here
three yeah i mean the three carrying
combos pretty scary yeah
well because i don't have any starting
point and i and i don't know what
they're fighting i'm gonna put her at a
c
maybe a b they were pretty scary yeah
they were scared
knowing what's to come i would say um
yeah maybe b
maybe b i'm just going to put them at c
because that baseline i wrote a
on this one really just one ela i think
it's eight
here yeah they're pretty terrifying if i
was all right okay i'll put it up to b
then i would be worried stepping outside
of that
yeah they were threatening her and [ __ ]
okay so let's give her a beat
and extra points for the baby being
there
a karen in the making
[Music]
okay so we got another one uh let's see
karen gets kicked out of a plane for
refusing a mask now
anti-mascarans are some of my favorite
breed so this should be good
[Applause]
oh everyone's clapping
videos
can you turn it up a little bit dan i
feel like it's maybe too quiet
oh did she say something about racism or
did i yeah she did she said that this
was racism that was happening
oh everybody's white or well here's one
black girl well it's racism against
white people that's what yeah
but i was just saying like everybody
there oh everybody else that's a good
point
i mean who's i just really i mean that
one i really enjoy white on white hate
crimes right
i really enjoyed the the the second one
that tries to start arguing the cop is
just like all right
i mean i don't again the mask thing
obviously they had it up to here with
her
this is her clapping that's awesome i
think just because
it the it got resolved pretty quick
there so i'm gonna have to give her a d
okay um right yeah
it was pretty epic to see her go though
i enjoyed it i mean don't get me wrong
but
like this girl would [ __ ] this girl
compared to her
and her whole gaggle of karen's scared
me straight
yeah this is fun i like this
i'm gonna go deep was that a sound bite
i i have a feeling that was a sound but
that was a sound bite
do you know me no i know who lives here
you know who lives here you know who
lives here yeah i do
how do you know that i don't let me tell
you how because i was here when this
neighborhood was built and i knew every
single person who bought in here
are you here since 2010. are you
serious right now so serious then you
know everybody you know everyone that
lives in my neighborhood
you live here we do live yes that's
great if you live here do you live here
yes [ __ ]
okay cheers i'm not giving you my
address
dude oh wow this is a high rank for me
oh my god because it's like it's like
how
could you possibly presume to know
everybody that lives in a neighborhood
you can see on our face the moment she
sees she's wrong but then she can't give
up she's gotta like
keep pushing oh she's like you might
live here not you
um and also like why do you care if
they're at the pool i
the whole thing is just like one of
those things is like
like wow this is this gives me big karen
vibes
i mean these girls were scarier so how
does see this this is kind of our bench
gotta go up um i still so maybe they go
up to
a uneasy about those girls maybe they go
up to an a and she goes
to a b yeah because she was i mean she
really
encapsulates the karen these people were
more
just i mean yeah i guess these were
super cairns i don't know what to say
you're right
honestly if i'm being honest they could
even be us
we can't say that no we have to reserve
s we can't do that
but you're right those are pretty scary
all right next up let me see here let's
see who's our next karen face
right here welcome the new challenger
this girl i love this
this is awesome hey hit f
a couple times on photoshop to full
screen yeah one sec
okay okay oh that's not it
there we go all righty karen the next
karen
on our docket is paper karen whatever
that means
let me see your papers she says
see more on my walk area things can you
stay away you're too close to me right
now
are you not wearing a mask can you step
away okay
can you show me your papers what what
can you move away i know can you show me
your papers can you move away
you wanna switch papers yes your
immigration
yeah your papers oh my god oh what a
[ __ ]
she's got such an evil that's that's
super caring dude i don't know
yeah let me see your papers like such a
power
girl like you have no you have and then
standing right in his face during covid
i mean hey you think so because that let
me see your papers is like i'm gonna
[ __ ] deport you
yeah which is kind of the most menacing
of all
it's like i'm gonna [ __ ] your whole life
up
yeah i gave her an a that was pretty
wild so cold as well
karen ranting about wearing a face mask
in her car
oh wait hold on probably 45 minutes oh i
love this
let me bring her photo up because i like
to introduce the karen
here she is this is awesome
i love this [ __ ] so here is karen
face mask edition instead of having it
on it's first time i've worn one
i am disoriented
i'm a little mad if you can't tell that
already like i'm very
i'm i'm frustrated but i don't feel good
physically like i can tell you right now
i wasn't getting enough oxygen and i
just had on one of these
little stupid things i feel dizzy
my hands are kind of tingly
my heart is beating fast so some of it's
an emotional reaction but some of it's a
physical reaction
i understand the virus is real okay i
understand the virus is real
friends look at the numbers and tell me
why
everybody's living in fear tell me why
we're putting these things on
and not being able to breathe i just
want to cry
like that's all i want to do is cry
because you can't see people's faces
oh you can't make human connections
i love that we can't hug people
we can't hold their babies oh i'm at the
end of it
i'm just simply at the end of it it
doesn't make sense
i can't believe how hard her life is
this
is all over being a little uncomfortable
for five minutes
it looks like she's in the parking lot
of a grocery shop yeah she probably had
to go shopping ralph's or some [ __ ]
or what i always say rouse but that's
like a west coast thing
what's this what's a grocery store
that's everywhere in the us
uh target i don't know a lot of them are
regional i mean walmart
sells they're all owned by the same
[ __ ] they just try to trick yourself
kroger
this doesn't make sense is that safeway
doing it the unsafe way
[Music]
and it's i'm not okay with it nothing
about what we're doing
is supported by the numbers that are out
there
those of you that know me like i am
one of the most compassionate caring
people you will ever meet
how is this right and i do care about
you but i
also care about me and my children and
my family and i do care about my
rights and it's probably the last time
i'm wearing this because i feel
terrible i feel emotionally terrible but
i feel
physically like it affected me so anyway
i have a feeling this was during the
beginning of when this started happening
and i feel like she was proven
wrong yeah well uh it says right on the
timestamp this is
may so yeah the number the numbers have
gone up
may was pretty good we were in there
yeah
was we were in some [ __ ] in may although
that's just when it was posted on this
twitter account
oh this is from a twitter account called
karen's gone wide
yeah this uh i've been keeping an eye on
this account
shout out to whoever runs this so hmm so
on one hand
i mean she's at least she's just doing
it to herself in the car
that's a really i think that counts for
a lot yeah as much as like
the care and energy there is i think
in her case it's really it's actually
more sad
yeah because you just see those effects
of
just living in a pandemic it is very
weird it's tough it's really but you
gotta wear the
it's very unnatural to be wearing a mask
the whole day and
you can't but you guys smile at people i
i was
i love that argument you can't i can't
see their faces when they smile
um but she's not bothering anyone she is
possibly
infecting people which is not good but
overall
it is a very iconic one it's one of my
favorite the truth is that this karen
how does this compare
um hair comparing because she got kicked
off
comparing i feel like maybe she's lower
yeah
because she got kicked off a plane
that's pretty happy yeah
we're getting a better sense for this
now all right the next karen
is let's see this who we've got oh just
a target logo
oh uh this is uh first person is the
thing so we don't actually have an image
apparently whoever this is she was
arrested so it's gotta be good
so this is target karen
finally we meet the end of the road i
have been looking forward to this [ __ ]
all my [ __ ] life so
uh target did she say she's been looking
forward to this [ __ ]
all her life yeah what could bot what
what possibly
could that mean like
[Music]
this this is good caring energy
i'm getting an s here
this shit's over this shit's over this
shit's over this shit's over
this shit's over yeah they're just gonna
put them back up there and sell them
[Music]
no i'm not doing it we don't we don't
want any of this anymore this is over
oh
[Music]
wow
okay all right you need to stop or we'll
take you in all right
like it's a punishment for me to go sit
in my range rover but i'm doing it i
just don't want you
enough you don't know she keeps grabbing
nobody right now you're calling me
annoying
fine i won't talk to anybody or bother
anybody that
is pretty incredible she's tearing down
racks
she's asserting her world beliefs on
everybody she's harassing everybody
she's even been arrested
she's bragging about her wealth it's
pretty high up there
pretty crazy though too so i don't know
like if she's having an episode yeah
because she said you're letting
everybody else do it why can't i do it
and that seems a little
light i think it's in reference to
the uh i think this happened right
around the time that the
riots had started so she's making
reference to like
god she is so exhausting i gotta give
her
she is such a f right that lady is the
worst
that's us for you i mean dude she's
she's the worst
what is she for you i don't know i'm
just surprised that you just go for that
she's a
so maybe she's a because i don't know
dude
she really annoyed me i'm kind of with
you on the s ethan
okay that one was pretty big what do you
guys think what do what do you guys
think
god i love oh then vin diesel loves her
zach and ian what do you write her
i'm gonna go on that one you say yeah i
wouldn't be
mad with an s all right oh wow there you
go do it there you go
captain america yeah there you go wow
yes that lady's the [ __ ] worst like
she's got all the racial
issues the class issues the harassment i
mean she hits everything
whoa what's going on here
all right let's find out i'm intrigued
is she using panties as a face mask
looks like it i'm intrigued i'm turned
on too
talk to me baby talk to me baby
karen uses underwear as a mask
and then they told her to wear a mask
because she wasn't black what oh she
says that
talk to me baby oh what is wrong with
you
girl oh well hold on her
at is crazy oh no not her yeah that's
not her
crazy karen's july you know celebrate
that corner of this shelf here freedom
according to hitler's they literally
can't tell me that i can't come in here
but they did
so you understand you're wearing a thong
on your face
you freak
she's trying to make people have just
lost it do you understand how crazy you
look
turn this off true story that last
post so incredibly frustrating
they were so rude um
unbelievable um they were wrong anyway
you know
going with a thong on your face how
uncomfortable are you making everyone
feel yeah and not covering your germs
right of course there's that
here's what's even better not wearing a
mask is rude
it's dangerous i mean if you're gonna
talk about being rude
you're the one endangering people you're
being rude preach it
as i was walking out of the storm
getting in my car um
there was a man who walked in no mask
they didn't say anything to him but that
was probably
because he was black and i might i think
they call that black privilege
oh wow what a way to end it
wow did you follow him the whole time do
you know right how did she even
she said that when she was leaving
disgusting
like they're supposed to tackle him
immediately
well i mean so so
i don't know that was sad
what do you see where do you see see the
immigration lady is just a bee now
i feel like that's not right oh wait no
no that's the
you don't live here i think she's on
that level
i think she's really you can't give her
more than that
okay she was just bitching in private
black privilege
yeah that's what you call it never heard
of it
unlike white privilege which is walking
around with a thong on your face and not
being taken to the looney bin
it's true though they're so [ __ ] sexy
she does look good i think there is a
distinction between the ones that um
that are freaking out in public versus
on their instagram yeah or whatever yes
right in fact that's true she was
covering her face i'm going to say it's
not as bad
as being uncovered well at least she put
panties
but it doesn't really cover well it
helps i'm just saying probably
maybe so let's give her a c she's on par
with the airplane lady
that was disgusting though when i hate
her
[Laughter]
good channel that hatred
let's see the face of our next karen
who do we have ah a shopping cart
i love these these are so fun this is
nine
um lovely young karen throwing a fit
over being asked to wear a mask lovely
young karen who wrote that
i think that was just the title of the
reddit wow this has 25 million views
holy crap
this is a viral karen moment
this is awesome i'm 25 million
oh wow
i don't give a [ __ ] i remember that
she is
[Music]
she just spent a lot of time shopping
for
[Music]
oh oh that's it okay
she's at checkout she's done she's done
all of her grocery shopping
and they're refusing to check her out
that's what i'm assuming
i'm not sure why that one went super
viral i mean some of the other ones i've
seen
are much wilder
it's pretty wild yeah i guess so
but like how does that compare i mean it
sounds low tier
it sounds it is kind of low i'm going to
be honest the views
set my expectations pretty high and i
feel like i was disappointed
a d let me think well no she's
definitely better than d because she was
throwing
groceries everywhere but she's not as
well i think she's a b
tier karen actually that's pretty high
for how disappointed you sounded
well i'm just trying to be objective
what do you guys think
i think c is more than fair i mean it's
b b
d not really impressed wow he's going
all the way down with e
i'm kind of i wait you said e yeah yeah
i said d
d i'm sorry d d but she's got to be
worse than this woman was just
complaining in her car that she was
throwing [ __ ] everywhere
it's more of my issue with the with the
camera work too far away
vertical i'm going to put her at a c
because she was throwing [ __ ]
i haven't thought about criticizing the
the production yeah that's hardly her
fault i mean
come on yeah but i mean you know you're
just taking in the whole
video as that's not a 26 million
view i got it yeah that's true
yeah but you can't com you can't uh put
that on her
and that's just not fair yeah but we're
not judge we're judging the the whole
package
no we're not we're judging the karen
this is we're raiding the karen not the
cameraman
i still think like if she had tipped
over
the shopping cart it would bump her up
several notches yeah but let's just put
her
just tossing it out i do think she
should be lower than the black
privilege girl really
no she was just she didn't bot i mean
she was just on instagram
that comment isn't yeah but she didn't
say it to the guy if she said it to the
guy she would be way up
when does it matter i guess it matters
but she still said it because she's not
in public she didn't you know what i'm
saying she was cowardly enough to not
say it so that's the thing i think
when we're judging on on karen energy
the karen energy
very much to me didn't she put it up
though on instagram
yeah but it's you doing it directly to
somebody makes you the ultimate
character right mm-hmm
well then this girl was throwing stuff
that's what i'm saying pretty much at
people
right if you look at who was recording
they weren't that far from the stuff
that's why i gave her a c you think she
should be higher yeah you
i mean i think c is a good conversation
let's stay on c yeah yeah
i i think she should be higher but i'm
uh i'm out voted here
oh well zach makes a compel why do you
think she should be higher zach
i i figure like if you saw that [ __ ] in
public like
i mean but that'd be insane right yeah i
mean i know we're watching a video but
like what if you're actually there
i mean i'd be yeah i'd definitely stop
and watch
well what if you're almost at the range
that it would hit you let's move her up
to b
let's move her up good call zach
all right all right let's see who's next
oh
what do we have here looks familiar 10
karen and coffee shop wearing masks and
coughing on someone
oh now we're cooking now we are cooking
[Music]
it says she doesn't know she's being
recorded
she was called out for not wearing them
and then she went coughed on them
oh when she saw the camera in her face
she freaked
she's like oh oh oh i just committed a
crime
[Music]
that's pretty high level caring yeah ass
dear
i think it's just because like during a
pandemic to go cough on someone i mean
that's
straight up a crime and just all you're
doing is picking up your coffee
yeah that's it you guys all agree with
your life real quick
i think i'd say yes too yeah that's
that's
and i love how like i just love the
defeat when she sees you
yeah yeah it's a full package
wow that's awesome
uh let's use next oh i don't know what
goes on here but i like it
the pointing the anger
let's see karen and trader joe's
refusing to wear a mask
oh she also made it on the news we have
a part two this is great i love it
this is day one this is opening day of
trader joe's in north hollywood
oh this is karen
woo oh come on
yeah it's so pathetic how people make it
political
oh my god and this is an la of all
places
so she apparently goes on the news let's
let's get the uh
before we make our judgment bro let's
see how far this goes
the woman in that cell phone video told
me a medical condition prohibits her
from wearing a mask
i do have a breathing problem basically
from my nose she said that night
the store manager alive without the mask
jj said go right ahead just for today
go ahead without a mask she said an
employee offered to shop for her
and she could wait outside but she said
she preferred to shop for herself
and the demand started yelling at her
phew
where you're at dude one of the
employees would like all shop for you
yeah
and she said no i have to have it my way
these people are so exhausting she said
she felt threatened
and nobody nobody was helping me so at
that point is what
they show in the video so anyone
harassing me to wear masks
you guys are violating federal law
attorney steve meister told me he
doesn't know what she's talking about
he said the cdc degree in law
ass mandate and he wishes they would my
doctor would not let me wear math
she was upset saying nobody would help
her in those moments i felt like they
were acting
like pigs
do i regret it no i mean not really in
those moments i don't
she was asked to leave but she didn't so
i stood there and i said i'm not moving
because i didn't do anything wrong
police were called no charges filed
and she went home she says she won't be
coming back to this trader joe's i think
that's a good idea for everybody
i mean that is pretty fantastic yeah
that's high level [ __ ] right there i
mean maybe
i think maybe an eight here yeah she's
not quite to the point of
s but
certainly at least an a what was the
walmart one
i forget because i don't see the face
the target
yeah the target one that was ripping all
the masks off
and then talking about the range rover
and yeah yeah yeah and bye
god what did what an ugly person i mean
like inside like what a what a
horrible human being
i think how she says that she feels
threatened but it's like she's
you're the one that's like you're
threatening everybody with the sickness
right
and also she's the one screaming and
putting her finger in everyone's face
nobody was even raising their voice to
her
who we got here oh no i know her
this is karen this is definitely like
final boss karen
let's watch you remember this one ela no
you're gonna love this
this is good [ __ ] is this your property
hi
i'm asking you got the craziest face why
are you watching because it's private
property because it's private property
so
are you defacing private property or is
this
so we're just saying absolutely your
signs and everything and that's good
this is not this is not the way to do it
okay
it's private property but if i did live
here and it was my property this would
be absolutely fine
and you don't know if i lived here or if
this is my property you actually do
know that's why we're asking oh really
because you live here right you said
because we know the person who does live
here oh okay
his house then i suggest you call him or
call the police or um because you're
accusing me of a crime correct what i'm
asking you is why are you and i'm not
answering you
okay that's fair that's fair so your
choices are to call the cops if you
believe i'm calling a crime
and i will more than be happy to talk to
him okay
thank you what's your name again i'm
lisa what you watching
lisa what's your name sir what's your
last name sir what is your first name
sir
i i'm not answering i'm not hugging you
you're talking to me i'm asking you the
questions
well we're not doing anything illegal
neither am i
actually really
black lives matter
that's karen and she's calling the cops
and this is gonna be really funny
because she knows the people who live
here personally
so he lives there there this was
actually
a viral uh karen moment there was a
whole news
let's see what happened because this is
in the news i somehow missed this one
oh dude her face is like uh
the face of the guarantee james jaime
juanito he's lived at this home for 18
years
18 years this isn't someone who just
moved in
business on tuesday afternoon he started
stenciling with chalk
my first instinct is again
this again well we're not doing anything
illegal neither am i
actually he lived there for 18 years i
assumed
maybe he was new to the neighborhood or
something
call the call if anything i feel like
they actually lisa and robert
i'll be right here and she decided to
call men with
guns because of my chalk art juanilo
says he knows many of the police
officers in the neighborhood and that
they didn't even get out of their car
shortly after this video was taken from
the person
this is san francisco's maybe richest
whitest hood
multiple people have identified the
woman in the video as lisa alexander
who's the ceo of a skincare line called
lafayette
oh my god the ceo of a skincare line
we reached out to her multiple times but
got no response
of course people is why black lives
matter i feel bad that she got like
probably her whole life [ __ ] up though
i mean i mean a little bit i don't know
just plain racist what's the problem
with the sign
no the of course there's nothing i just
feel bad that like
i don't feel a tiny bit it's just crazy
how like one
stupid decision i didn't even realize it
was chalk at first
yeah juanillo says he's a proud gay
filipino who knows what discrimination
feels like this guy this is
the first time we can all agree on that
yeah i love how he handled that he's a
legend
so well she's definitely got karen vibes
forever so hey
that's there for me really oh yeah well
she called the police on a dude doing
his chalk stencil so that's pretty epic
on his own house you guys think ester i
mean the only thing that gives me a
reservation is she's very polite with
her care and energy no but it's like
cold
psycho oh for sure no it's psychotic but
at least she's polite because she's
actually
wrong yeah i mean no but she ended up
calling the police so i don't think she
thought she was ever wrong
i think she knew there was a chance
because obviously she didn't know who
actually lives there right that was made
up
you guys think s or a i i'd go ass
i personally go probably a i don't think
tie breaker yeah i'd i'd give her an a
yeah it wasn't enough chaotic energy
exactly
exactly like it's definitely bad but
at least she wasn't screaming you know
which a lot of these are
that's a fair point even though it was
like psycho threatening
cold energy but she wasn't screaming but
look at her eyes though
yeah it's i don't know sometimes you
don't have to scream to be so
uh she's scared yeah she's she's top
scary
but like are we really gonna compare to
coughing on somebody
well if you call so if you call the
police on somebody you kind of
are willing to and he's kind of
dark-skinned
you're willing to hmm
i don't know i don't feel the s in my
heart that's fine i think it's a tear
now this girl we all know she's mega
famous karen
and i feel an s tear coming up here
the dog part the infamous dog park
actually this woman got charged for a
crime of reported false
false police reports report this one
went like mega
[ __ ] viral 45 million views
wow i'm sure everyone's seen this don't
come close
right yeah would you
she's just so wrapped up in the moment
threatening my life
please tell them whatever you like
so the back story as i understand it is
that he asked her to please put her dog
on a leash because
he's scared of dogs or wow whatever it's
a dog you're supposed to have your dogs
on a leash here
and so sh if it's not a dog park you're
technically supposed to have them on a
leash
i feel so bad for this poor dog look how
she's handling it i mean what the hell
lady
look at this poor dog you can't for like
no reason you can't
spend a dog by the neck what is he doing
he's recording me and threatening me
dude please put your dog down it's hard
to watch honestly
me it's hard to watch i feel so bad for
the dog that it's kind of hard to look
anywhere else yeah
but she's asked well the thing is like
she's super
unhinged let's see uh
she's was arrested and hit with a one
count of foster reporting an incident in
the third degree
a misdemeanor in manhattan was this in
central park she also lost her job
doesn't look like it
i think it was yeah i think so her life
was ruined from this video as well
yeah yeah which
you know i don't feel this way about
life's good enough i don't yeah actually
i don't feel bad in this case for her
because
his life requested she was she was
trying to [ __ ]
she was like saying horrible lies about
him
so the previous late good thing it was
recorded
really i mean the previous lady is kind
of like the same case calling the cops
during like his response was to the
police brutality
like you know what's going on in the
country with the police she didn't
she just said hey i think this dude's
committing a crime she was like he's
threatening me
yeah that's different right she was so
she was trying to provoke like an
armed response this woman's like a
danger to society
frankly yeah she's asked here there's no
really debating that is there yeah no
that's
us yeah especially choking the dog while
yeah that poor dog what the hell man oh
interesting
karen comes over to a group to tell them
to play
american music i love that
what exactly is american music i don't
know
talk to them because you have
unfortunately
oh i know i know
is
bye bye bye
bye bye
in america thank you
they're puerto rican is that he said i
think yeah
[Laughter]
yeah that's that's the a tier in my
opinion yeah
god the husband or whoever like the
uncomfortable smile is
you know it's brutal i i often hear this
and
i don't really understand it but you
hear from these racists like
you can you're only allowed to partake
in american activities in america
american music
you're only allowed to eat you're only
allowed to
speak english
yeah it's it's just
it's it's so
weird it's like such it's such a weird
misunderstanding of
even what america is weirdos
um we're coming up on the end here
we should pick our favorite karen by the
way at the end this woman i like the
lighting very dramatic
this is angry karen break tears down
black lives
matter mural unprovoked awesome
do not do this this is stage my aunt
then put up your own stuff this is not
this is my freedom of speech this is my
this is my freedom of speech and george
soros you don't need this
violence oh my god
you are being violent
what they're trying to have a mural for
george floyd and she's tearing it up
what up stick oh arguing it you are
brainwashed there's a stage like
stop people oh this is
[Music]
such a hateful person
ah i mean not much was shown but that's
pretty high level i mean that's
like assault it's racism it's q anon
vibes
it's ass i love it yeah
trump loves q anon i said i love it
i was doubting if i heard you right but
he clarified
oh we needed to have instead of s q
q and not so maybe we should do a
um we should do a final round to
to crown the cube here let's see there's
three more
here we go top three
q energy there too emt saying stabbing
victim harassed because karen
wants them to move the ambulance out of
the way
hi ma'am what's your uh what's your view
on all this
i think that he needs to know who the
ambulance
yeah because he's blocking you in yeah
so the ambulance is dealing with the
stabbing victim should move because
you're inconvenienced the world is not
going to stop
if that was critical they wouldn't be
sitting in a parking lot
right yeah okay so
she wants to get out oh yeah i'm sorry
that people don't like that that's just
tough [ __ ]
why are you harassing first responders
doing their job though
no i asked them to move i wasn't
harassing oh you're on
[Music]
listen
if that was an emergency crisis they
wouldn't stay there
um i'm not super impressed this is low
tier carrying yeah
i mean i unders i understand wanting to
get out
you know [ __ ] that let's put her with
the ds
out get out get out
can't find my mouse here it is all right
who else we got two more left
oh she's covering her face oh
karen won't calm down hmm i think i have
seen this one
karen are you okay
can you explain to me calmly no because
you're attacking me right now i'm not
attacking you
ma'am you flicked me off you're ready to
take it
guys this is her license plate number
she lives here this is her address
[Music]
unless she takes the virus you cut me
off and flipped me off and now you're
playing the victory
ma'am would you like to calm down oh my
god this is so sick
guys she flipped me off she literally
clipped me off and then she
tried to come home she's karen karen
would you like to calm down and have a
conversation why are you
wait hang on he followed her no yeah
this is kind of weird i think this guy's
a little [ __ ] up too
sounds like they had an altercation and
he followed her home
yeah and then he's showing her license
and [ __ ]
yeah and calling her karen i don't know
i don't like this guy's vibe
and clearly this woman is like not okay
yeah
yeah i need to see the full story here
you know
i don't like this guy's vibe yeah
he's relentless i'm trying to let you
talk
just bounce look at her
okay she flipped you off move on dude
this guy's kind of the karen
i have to say he's dude he's the karen
he's the ken he totally he thinks she's
the karen but he's the karen
what did we say todd todd yeah todd god
bro you're a [ __ ] i actually i'm
getting crazy todd energy from the guy
filming
just move on so what so she caught you
off why is she fortunate
she literally flipped me off she cut me
off okay
i have it on camera and then you
followed her home bro you're a todd
[ __ ] you try driving in israel that
happens every five minutes
i gotta say i don't know about this one
i think you're a todd bro
he's got crazy i'm gonna give him a b
for being a todd
i think he gets a b yeah yeah wow [ __ ]
that guy
kind of i mean i don't know the whole
story but he fall first of all
if you follow someone home and then
hit run at them and the driver with your
phone on getting their license plate and
all this
i mean dude yeah nah and finally
what is this is there tongue out
maybe oh oh a karen zombie
oh no this one is incredible i have seen
this one
[ __ ]
oh
oh
oh
you think she wins she might just be
like crazy
yo mom baby girl who the [ __ ] is baby
girl
hello he just called hello
what are you doing
crazy [ __ ] you know you have the best
night at the
clock
oh
why is she so obsessed with trying to
get in there look at her head it's
already bleeding
damn crazy look at the top of her head
bad grain
i want to go check her you hate to see
it boy out of here
stupid ass
[Music]
arrested is this karen
energy or just like crazy yeah i mean
that's a good question i don't know i i
think she was really drunk too
dude because i don't understand that
argument she got bounced out of the bar
and she was wasted and she and then
starts head
running head first into the doors and
licking and seeing some crazy [ __ ] at
bars man
i never see anything like that in my
life i mean that is
what do you guys think is this ester or
do we give her a pass
yeah i mean i i had to include it
because it's just so [ __ ] funny i i
don't know if this is really
an exemplary uh karen to be honest i
think that's very
um very fitting for a q tier
because it's just kind of like the
x factor next level
not necessarily so you think she's the
ultimate karen
say i'm not sure she's the ultimate
karen she's more i agree she's kind of
cute like in a whole nother realm yeah
but ian and zach do you guys
where do you place her on the power
scale i love this video so much
um yeah but can't rate the karen
i i mean is it really a caring
i don't think so yeah there's a lot of
skepticism yeah i don't think it's a
karen i think it's just a crazy ass lady
[ __ ] hilarious though yeah
yeah i don't know it's just
i'm confused so let's just yeah it's
tough
yeah let's keep her off the scoreboard
so we've got just to recap we've got
girl
who tore down the the mask
display at target we've got coughing
in someone's face right we've got the
central park dog
choker and then we've got the black
lives matter
anti-protester actually i think i know
who i want to pick
who you got i think my q level
is the coughing coffee shop
i mean it's the craziest bitchiest
[ __ ] just so
stu i just the fact that you would go up
and cough on someone during a pandemic
is just so [ __ ] i'm moving everyone
down
so that she can occupy her own tear
oh but what do you guys think i i gotta
put the target lady on the same tier
really
but you have to choose one just the
for like tearing all those masks
i mean she was crazy don't get me wrong
she didn't cough on anyone damn
i mean that's true
you see the threat of the physical harm
is that is that is that really karen
you know yeah she caught well
because it's the cough it's like you
could pass it off it's like oh i didn't
i was just coughing well what do you i
mean uh
ela who's yours here
um that's pretty good
she was definitely next level
anyone else he and zach
going for a kind of a curveball i'd go
trader joe's karen
the one that made on the news wait which
one was
this one uh yeah you give her the
coveted s rank i think that's just
insane
like it's [ __ ] the fact she made it
on the news is even better
there's something to be said about the
the complete lack of regret
even after the fact i agree like she was
really defending
her actions in that news club but this
lady went and coughed on somebody dude
yeah yeah no that i can't really argue
with that i mean that is
that's pretty top tier but it's an
interesting choice
for her for for trader joe's for trader
karen
and eli you guys haven't given me an
answer we have to decide here
we are not leaving until we decide
i'm just not sure i guess what's the
criteria anymore
it's in your heart and soul i mean i
picked my favorite it's the
f lady which one the queue
oh are we picking our favorite like what
are we doing here and energy
you're confusing me caring energy
but i think we decided she's not really
a karen
wait the zombie is that the one you were
talking about yeah okay she's not a
character
she's just a zombie right a zombie
is disqualified crazy
[Music]
all right nobody nobody's giving me a
compelling argument here
okay so i pick his target you know
for better or worse that's my top tier
yep i would go with your pk then
i mean yeah yeah
probably the target lady hmm that's two
for target
so wait we've got these two accelerate
and then so target and coughing
well for narrowing it down to two i
think i'd go with the coughing one
there it is coughing lighting wins we
have a champion
there it is the karen i love it well
done man
there it is the karen olympics 2020
we have our grand champion coughing in a
coffee shop let's watch it one more time
just to do you have some kind of
triumphant music uh
hmm yeah that we can kind of play over
this let me see what number was she
chariots of fire
congratulations to coffee shop karen
she is our victor she is number one
[Music]
top caring energy
delivering a cough hurry around the
world
oh i'm being recorded ah karen we got
you
we got you this time girl
maybe next time you'll you'll be all
right
dude well
[Music]
what can you say i mean congratulations
to her
congratulations to keemstar on getting
uh teddy fresh and theodora's college
fund
thank you to the greatest members in the
world thank you for watching
our podcast number 27 in the united
states what an
honorable position to be wow thank you
to all the karen's congratulations
number one karen and i want to say sorry
again to all the actual cool karens
yeah i really do feel bad and um don't
worry your name will be cool again
i agree true it's almost over shout out
to the cool karens
congratulations to keemstar for getting
theodore's college fund
and congratulations to leafy on his
speed run of trying to get banned
from pokemon server as well as youtube
pokemon pokemon pokemon it was kind of
between pokemon and pokemon
[ __ ] pokeman
uh like gucci mane thank you all
we will see you on well we'll see you
tomorrow for h3 after dark
and then on monday cody co will be with
us which is very exciting
so with that being said see you guys
next time